Das Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch. Je höher man spielt, umso mehr Medikamente gibt es auch. Was ich in den letzten 14 Jahren mitbekommen habe, Ibuprofen wird wie Smarties verteilt.
Für jedes kleine Aua gibt es quasi pauschal Ibuprofen.
Ich muss echt sagen, dass ich schon etwas betroffen habe. Müssen wir unbedingt an unsere Landesverbände gehen und über Fußballlehrer, über Trainer einfach eine Sensibilisierung hinkriegen.
Jonas Hummels, Neven Subotic und am Ende DFB-Präsident Fritz Keller. Sie alle haben sich geäußert im Zuge einer groß angelegten Recherche zum Thema Schmerzmittel. Und darüber wollen wir jetzt hier sprechen in diesem Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch Nummer 41, zu dem ich euch ganz herzlich begrüße. Mein Name ist Max Jacob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer bei Twitter und freue mich, dass ich zwei der Rechercheure hier bei mir begrüßen darf. Sie beide arbeiten beim Correctiv und sie beide haben Monate, ich weiß nicht wie viele, aber es waren bestimmt einige, Arbeitszeit in diese Recherche gesteckt. Zum einen Jonathan Sachse, der Ed J Sachse, auf Twitter. Hallo Jonathan.
Aber da sieht man mal, an wie vielen zarten Fäden das so hängt. Da muss ein Trainer sein, der irgendwie eine klare Position hat. Die Spieler bringen, gerade die jungen Spieler, die so reinkommen und auch erst mal Sachen übernehmen, die sie von anderen mitkriegen. Das ist auch nochmal das Beispiel Jonas Hummels hat da auch schon gesagt. Den Trainer kann ich jetzt hier nicht nennen. Den hat er zwar im Interview gesagt, aber wir haben ihn jetzt nicht vorher konfrontiert. Aber es gab einen Trainer, der auch momentan in einer der beiden Bundesliga noch Trainer ist, der zu ihm das eigentlich vorgelebt hat. Ich war damals Spieler, ich habe regelmäßig Schmerzmittel genommen und ich habe natürlich nicht aufgehört. Also kriegst du das ja wohl auch hin. Oder ein anderes Beispiel, Subotage sagt diesen Satz, stell dir vor, das ist jetzt das wichtigste Spiel deiner Karriere, das ist jetzt das Champions League-Finale. Würdest du denn wirklich heute nicht spielen? Wenn du jetzt sagst, doch stimmt, ich würde spielen, dann spielst du heute bitte auch.
Vor allem, weil das Irre ist, eine solche anekdotische Erinnerung von Nevin Subotage, die kann man ja dann verknüpfen mit einer anekdotischen Erinnerung eben von Thomas Fröhlich, der ja auch ein, ich würde es jetzt einfach extern als Hallowacherlebnis definieren, ohne mit ihm selbst gesprochen zu haben hatte, nämlich eben 1998, als der VfB Stuttgart im Europapokalfinale der Pokalsieger stand gegen den FC Chelsea, dort mit 0 zu 1 verloren hat und einer der Stuttgarter Spieler aber dann nicht am Ende auf der Finalparty war, sondern zusammen mit Thomas Fröhlich, also nicht beide, aber der Spieler hat Blut gespuckt und Thomas Fröhlich hat ihm Infusionen gegeben und an seinem Bett gewacht die ganze Nacht, um zu überprüfen, dass er auch wirklich durch diese Nacht durchkommt. Diese beiden Erinnerungen kann man ja quasi direkt nebeneinander stellen und dann hat man ja schon das ganze Spektrum von Trainer, Spieler und Mannschaftsarzt und den Folgen, die es haben kann.
Ja, bei ihm muss man noch als Ergänzung sagen zu der Geschichte von damals, er hat ihn dann interviewt und gefragt, was hast du eigentlich noch genommen? Bei einem Teil hat er mitbekommen, dass er ihm Ibuprofen, glaube ich, war, das bei ihm genommen hat. Diclofenac. Ja, genau, also da war er sozusagen beteiligt. Dann hat er ihn danach noch mal interviewt, hast du noch was genommen? Hat er gesagt, Aspirin habe ich auch noch genommen. So Aspirin als Blutverdünner, bekannt auch, unter anderem. Und so die Kombination, seine Interpretation hat dann dazu geführt, dass er dann angefangen hat, Blut zu spucken, genau.
Und dann, finde ich, haben wir ja hier mit diesem Thema Schmerzmittel, wenn wir noch kurz bei den Ärzten bleiben, ja noch ein weiteres Problem, nämlich das Problem, dass die Indikation, ob ich Schmerzmittel brauche, ja höchst subjektiv ist. Ich kann, glaube ich, in den seltensten Fällen einen Spieler ansehen und sagen, du brauchst was oder du brauchst jetzt gerade nicht was, sondern wenn der Spieler kommt und sagt, ich habe Schmerzen, dann ist das ja schwierig zu überprüfen. Das ist ja dann nochmal eine weitere Komplexität, auch jetzt aus Sicht der Mannschaftsärzte. Was sollen sie denn dann tun?
Ja, das ist ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt, denn ein Mannschaftsarzt hat ja auch nur begrenzte Zeit dann in der Arbeit mit der Mannschaft. Und da kommen dann auch in der Bundesliga verschiedene Konstellationen zum Tragen, in denen ein Mannschaftsarzt vielleicht seine eigene Praxis noch hat in der Stadt und irgendwie nur halbtags dann als Mannschaftsarzt zur Verfügung steht oder auch Konstellationen, in denen ein Mannschaftsarzt immer vor Ort ist. Aber es ist eben wichtig, dann im Dialog mit dem Spieler erst mal herauszufinden, was ist der Grund für den Schmerz? Ist es einfach eine Belastung gewesen, jetzt am Vortrag von mir aus? Oder ist es eine Kontaktverletzung? Etwas, das man noch einigermaßen tolerieren kann, wenn man weiß, okay, ich kann jetzt strukturell nichts kaputt machen, es kann kein Band kaputt gehen dadurch, sondern es ist quasi nur eine Stabilisierung. Auch mit Tape wird dafür gearbeitet und so. Das ist ja auch alles legitim. Das ist ja auch wirklich dann der Sinn und Zweck von Schmerzmitteln, dass man Spieler dann auch auf diese Art und Weise insofern spielfähig bekommt, dass sie eben nicht in eine Situation kommen, wo sie dann selbstständig und missbräuchlich mit Schmerzmitteln hantieren. Und wenn, glaube ich, dann das Bewusstsein bei den Vereinen auch ein bisschen größer ist, dass man merkt, gesundheitliche Risiken von Schmerzmitteln sind möglich. Und dazu gehört eben auch, dass Verletzungen verschleppt werden können, wenn ich eben über Wochen nach einer Belastung mit Schmerzmitteln regeneriere und denke, dadurch sind meine Muskeln dann schneller wieder fit, ich kann schneller wieder eine höhere Trainingsintensität fahren, kann dadurch meinen Trainingsrhythmus beibehalten und kann am Wochenende spielen. Und das mache ich eine Woche, zwei Wochen, drei Wochen. Dann kann irgendwann der Moment kommen, in dem eine Muskelfaser reißt beispielsweise und dann fällt ein Spieler aus, vier bis sechs Wochen. Das heißt, dann muss er bezahlt werden, kann aber nicht spielen. Und ich glaube, wenn die Vereine realisieren, dass durch diese medizinische Arbeit zwischen Mannschaftsarzt und Spieler so viel davor weggenommen werden kann, dass eben auch Geld gespart werden kann. Denn ich glaube, ein wichtiger Punkt in dieser ganzen Debatte ist eben das ganze Geld, was im Spiel ist. Und wenn man das dann schafft, zumindest die Mannschaftsärzte so zu sensibilisieren, dass sie in den Dialog treten können mit dem Spieler und der Spieler auch offen ist und sagt, ich habe Schmerzen, das geht über den Punkt X hinaus und dann bringt es eben nichts mit Schmerzmitteln, dann ist schon mal was geschaffen. Denn wenn ein Spieler ständig ausfällt wegen Folgeschäden, die entstehen, weil er seine Signale des Körpers irgendwie ignoriert und eben über den Schmerzpunkt hinaus trainiert, dann ist das natürlich ein Punkt, wo jede Menge Geld auch verloren geht. Und ich hoffe, dass da so ein bisschen vielleicht eine höhere Sensibilisierung stattfindet, dass eben solche Fälle vermieden werden können.
Aber ist das nicht das klassische Problem, was wir jetzt auch rund um Corona erleben? There is no glory in prevention. Also wenn du etwas verhindert hast, dass dann eben nicht eingetreten ist, kannst du ja auch nie sagen, weil ich damals XY getan habe, haben wir jetzt ganz viel Geld gespart, lieber Aufsichtsratsvorsitzender, weil unser Spieler nicht verletzt war. Ist das nicht da ein großes Problem?
Also es gibt ja Möglichkeiten, dass man mit Belastung umgeht und dass man danach regeneriert. Also da hat sich auch schon viel getan, muss man sagen. Also wenn wir da mit Spielern gesprochen haben, die in den 80er, 90er Jahren noch aktiv waren, das waren schon teilweise absurde Sachen, die man da gehört hat. So im Sinne von Belastungssteuerung und Trainingssteuerung und Regeneration und so, heute sind ja die Bundesligisten da top aufgestellt. Also da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten, Kältebecken, Sauna, Behandlung, Physiotherapie, blablabla. Aber trotz allem ist es natürlich so, dass Schmerz an sich, haben wir auch vorhin schon darüber gesprochen, entsteht. Und dann ist die Frage, wie gehen wir damit um? Und was sind die Gründe für Schmerzen, die eben längerfristig sind? Und ich weiß tatsächlich nicht, ob in dem Betrieb Bundesliga, dann gerade auch bei Vereinen, die am Dreitagesrhythmus spielen, ob da genügend Zeit besteht, dass die Spieler sich entsprechend auskurieren können.
Es ist ja auch schwierig, diesen Punkt zu treffen zwischen eine Belastung ist eine Belastung und Schmerz ist Schmerz. Also komme ich ein bisschen zurück auf das, was ich schon gesagt habe, aber eben diese subjektive Indikation. Und dann gleichzeitig ja auch, wenn wir auf die Rolle der Spieler kommen, auf der einen Seite, dass man festhalten kann, viele wissen wahrscheinlich nicht, was sie tun. Und selbst wenn sie es wüssten, würden sie es wahrscheinlich trotzdem tun. Das kann man ja ganz gut aus so manchem Protokoll herauslesen, das ihr gemacht habt, weil eben der Spieler, der möchte Geld verdienen, der möchte Erfolg haben. Leistungssportler sind ja auch ein gewisser Typ Mensch, also natürlich mit verschiedenen Schattierungen. Aber du musst gewisse Grundeigenschaften haben. Und dazu gehört eben auch, über Grenzen hinwegzugehen. Sonst wirst du kein Leistungssportler.
Genau, dann wäre die Schussfolgerung, wenn man sagt, es ist ein Problem. Es ist gesundheitsschädigend. Man kann damit seine Leistung vielleicht sogar steigern, weil man sonst vielleicht gar nicht auf dem Platz hätte stehen können. Dann muss es reguliert werden. Das ist ja die Frage, die man im nächsten Schritt diskutieren müsste, wie man es genauso auch bei klassischem Doping machen würde. Wenn die Spieler, wir betragen es mal kurz auf andere Sportarten, die noch bekannter sind für Doping, auch wenn es im Fußball eine Rolle spielt. Wenn jetzt im Wintersport alle irgendwie die ganze Zeit mit Doping weitermachen und auch wissen, dass es sogar gesundheitsschädigend sein kann, dann ist das ja kein Grund zu sagen, wir lassen das einfach laufen. Das ist für mich genau der Punkt, wo man die Frage stellen muss, muss da mehr reguliert werden, wenn das System es selber nicht hinkriegt, aus den ganzen Gründen, die wir jetzt schon genannt haben. Das wiederum, dann sind wir wieder bei der Dopingfrage. Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, ob wir die vorhin schon einmal definiert haben, aber es gibt ja mehrere Kriterien, ab wann steht was auf der Dopingliste. Und zwei Sachen, die aus Sicht von manchen Experten auf dem Gebiet erfüllt sind, bei Schmerzmitteln, ist, wenn es auf eine Art und Weise genommen wird, also missbräuchlich, dann kann es gesundheitsschädigend sein. Das ein Kriterium, warum Sachen auf Dopings kommen. Das andere ist der leistungssteigende Effekt. Auch den kann man zumindest diskutieren mit dieser Frage, hätten sie sonst überhaupt spielen können. Oder ich nehme es prophylaktisch, weil normalerweise habe ich ab der zweiten Halbzeit Schmerzen und kann bestimmte Wege nicht mehr gehen. Die kriege ich dann noch hin. Dadurch habe ich dann die Leistung gesteigert. Da gibt es Leute wie Thomas Fröhlich, den Mannschaftsarzt, der diese Diskussion angestoßen hat. Dann gibt es Leute aus dem Anti-Doping-Labor in Köln, was die Hoheit über die Analytik zumindest in Deutschland bei dem Thema hat. Die sagen auch, die Diskussion müssen wir auf jeden Fall führen. Die sagen das auch schon seit zehn Jahren. Jetzt haben sie das quasi nochmal erneuert bei uns. Warum kommen Schmerzblödsinn zumindest zu bestimmten Definitionen? Nicht auf die Dropping-Liste, bzw. es sollte eine Ausnahmegelung dafür geben. Zu deinem Punkt noch mal von vorn. Es geht ja wirklich nicht darum, zu sagen, wer vor dem Spiel den Schmerz erbitte nimmt, der sollte nicht auf dem Platz stehen. Sondern es geht wirklich um die Beständigkeit und die Art der Dosierung. Wenn du jetzt eine englische Woche nimmst, oder nehmen wir jetzt mal gerade die Woche, und die interessante Frage, wie viele Schmerzblödsinn werden jetzt eigentlich gerade genommen, wo du fast aus dem Kaltstart, jetzt mal provokativ formuliert, plötzlich alle paar Tage auf dem Platz stehen musst. Und teilweise geht es wirklich auch bei jedem Spiel darum, nehmen wir jetzt mal Werder Bremen oder so, wo es für jedes Spiel wirklich fast gefühlt das entscheidende Spiel für den Abstandskampf ist. Und du willst jedes Spiel jetzt irgendwie mitspielen, da ist ja unabhängig von den Zuschauern trotzdem die Frage, wie belastbar bist du. Und gibt es da Spieler, wo jetzt die Vereine vielleicht sehen, durch dieses Doping-Kontroll-Formular, was sie immer wieder angeben müssen, alle paar Tage, da steht jedes Mal stehen wieder die Schmerzblödsinn auf. Ab wann müsste ein Verein dann oder durch ein anderes System und reguliert werden? Jetzt geht es nicht. Du kannst jetzt nicht das dritte Spielenfolge mit den Schmerzblödeln spielen. Jetzt müssen wir stoppen. Jetzt muss immer noch das eingesetzt werden. Das finde ich, sollte man auf jeden Fall diskutieren.
Womit wir dann auch so ein bisschen die Rolle der Vereine auch schon mit rein gedacht haben. Wie ist denn euer Eindruck davon, wie das Problembewusstsein bei den Vereinen ist und auch der Umgang damit? Ich vermute, ihr werdet auch an Bundesliga und andere Vereine Anfragen gestellt haben zu diesem Thema. Oder man kann es auch herauslesen aus einem solchen öffentlichen Fall wie Ivan Klasnitsch. Was glaubt ihr, wie groß da das Problembewusstsein für Schmerzmittelmissbrauch ist?
Also wir haben an alle Vereine da Anfragen gestellt, ob sie uns mal einfach drei generelle Fragen zum Thema Schmerzmittel beantworten möchten. Ich habe jetzt nicht mehr alle drei Fragen im Kopf, aber eine Frage war, was schätzen sie, wie groß er hat? Also wir haben uns auf die FIFA-Studien bezogen und dann gefragt, glauben sie auch, dass in Deutschland der Schmerzmissbrauch ein echtes Problem ist? Und es hat uns kein einziger Verein diese Fragen beantwortet. Das fanden wir jetzt erstmal überraschend. Das waren wirklich nur allgemeine Metafragen. Es wurde viel damit argumentiert. Wir haben das jetzt nicht wortwörtlich parat, aber von Borussia Dortmund habe ich das noch in Erinnerung. Die mischen sich doch sonst auch nicht. Stellen sie mal vor, ihr Arbeitgeber macht das und berichtet über persönliche medizinische Fragen, obwohl wir wirklich ganz abstrakte Fragen nicht gefragt haben, wie sieht das beim Spieler XY aus? Obstrakte Fragen gestellt haben. Das war so ein Punkt, wo wir gemerkt haben, dass es auf jeden Fall ein Problem darüber zu reden ist. Man muss auch sagen, die Spieler, die sich jetzt vor der Kamera geäußert haben, also mit Zubotic, mit dem sind wir nicht über die Presseabteilung gegangen, um das Interview mit ihm zu vereinbaren. Auch bei Thomas Fröhlich ist der Weg nicht so gewesen. Irgendwann mussten wir auch ganz klar solche Entscheidungen treffen, um zu den für die Öffentlichkeit relevanten Ergebnissen zu kommen. Weil scheinbar die Presseabteilung dann wirklich als Blockierer an dem Moment wirken. Wir haben eine andere Sache, die wir auch gemacht haben. Torsten berichten auch gar nicht auf, dass wir relativ früh mal eine Umfrage gestellt haben an alle Nachwuchsleistungszentren. Da ging es noch mehr um das Doping-Thema, aber dass sie einfach mal eine Umfrage verbreiten zum Thema, wie Schmerzproblem auch ein Thema ist, auch da haben wir solche Antworten bekommen. Es gab sogar noch einen dritten Punkt, Arne, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, ganz am Anfang, als wir unsere Umfrage gemacht haben zu Schmerzproblemmissbrauch. Amateurfußball haben wir auch aktiv in der Regionalliga die zweiten Mannschaften angeschrieben. Wir sind teilweise wieder bei den selben Pressesprechern gelandet, auf die wir später noch mal zugegangen sind. Und auch da war das wiederkehrend, also teilweise Copy-and-Paste-Antworten. Wir können das nicht weiterleiten, auch wenn es anonym ist, dass es medizinische Belange gibt, gegen die Öffentlichkeit nichts an. Also es ist ein echtes Tabuthema.
Genau, also es ist natürlich dann auch wahnsinnig komplex und wir haben wahnsinnig viele Vereine und verschiedene Personen in der Verantwortung, die dann auch unterschiedlich darauf reagieren. Und wir haben natürlich auch mit verschiedenen Mannschaftsärzten über dieses Thema gesprochen, die dann uns gesagt haben, ja natürlich sind das Probleme. Wir können jetzt die Spieler nicht 24 Stunden am Tag beobachten, das was wir eben schon angesprochen haben, aber mein Eindruck war, dass es da durchaus auch Ärzte gibt, ohne jetzt dafür alle zu sprechen, die dann schon auch realisieren, was ist die fußballerische Realität, die wir jetzt haben. Das heißt, ist es jetzt wichtig, einen Spieler für das erste Spiel in der Saison fit zu spritzen? Oder ist es nicht vielleicht wichtiger, den Spieler dann fit zu machen, wenn ein wichtiges Spiel ansteht, was über Auf- und Abstieg entscheidet? Diese Abstufungen, die gibt es schon. Das heißt, das sind dann immer Einzelfallentscheidungen. Aber der Arzt hat eben auch bewusst gesagt, das passiert. Man kann Spieler fit spritzen, das passiert. Und die Frage ist dann eben, wie hoch ist dann die Dunkelziffer? Das heißt, wie viel passiert dann in einem Bereich, den wir nicht mitbekommen? Und welche Möglichkeiten der Kontrollen bestehen dann eben, um das ein bisschen abzudämpfen und einschätzen zu können? Und gerade in der Regionalliga, weil Jonathan das gerade schon angesprochen hatte, ist das ein sehr interessantes Thema, weil das ja so ein bisschen Zwitterliga ist in deutschen Fußball, würde ich mal sagen. Man hat Vereine, die mehr oder weniger über relativ einfache Strukturen kommen, wo nicht so viel Geld dahinter steht, die jetzt als in Anführungsstrichen Dorfvereine verschrieben sind. Aber andererseits hat man auch Spiele, Vereine mit einem unheimlich hohen öffentlichen Interesse, mit wahnsinnig vielen Zuschauern und Mitgliedern, gerade in der Regionalliga West beispielsweise, wo natürlich auch Profi-Strukturen dann vorliegen. Ich kann mich an eine Begebenheit erinnern, als ich dann mit Trainer und Co-Trainer eines Regionalligisten aus der Regionalliga Südwest in Kontakt war. Die Kickers auch damals. Da habe ich es tatsächlich geschafft, dass ich vor der Mannschaft in der Kabine stand und gesagt habe, wir recherchieren jetzt um das Thema Schmerzmittelbesuch im Fußball und wir brauchen dazu Daten. Ganz wichtig. Ich habe die Spieler dann darüber informiert, dass sie die Möglichkeit haben, bei uns anonymisiert zu melden, was sie nehmen und wie viel sie davon nehmen. Dass wir überhaupt so weit gekommen sind, war schon eine wahnsinnige Überraschung eigentlich. Dass wir überhaupt in die Kabine kamen, um über dieses Thema zu reden. Das heißt, es war so ein Punkt, wo ich dachte, es gibt auch die Beispiele, wo sich Trainer und Co-Trainer eben proaktiv mit dieser Thematik auseinandersetzen und dann eben auch was zur Verfügung stellen an Ressourcen. Ende vom Lied war dann leider, dass niemand teilgenommen hat.
Hast du dich nicht richtig motiviert, Arne?
Ja, ich bin kein Jürgen Klopp, was das angeht, wahrscheinlich.
Diggy geht jetzt da raus und dann füllt er diese Umfrage aus und dann knallt er sie weg.
Ja, ich hatte so eine PowerPoint-Präsentation vorbereitet, wo aus ein bisschen unsere Recherchergebnisse da schon zusammengefasst waren. So ein paar Studien, so ein paar Fälle, dass man jetzt auch die Spieler dann nicht überfordert mit der Thematik. Ich hatte gehofft, okay, vielleicht in der Regionalliga bekommt man den einen oder anderen dazu, weil eben auch, und jetzt auf einer anderen Ebene in der Regionalliga keine Doping-Kontrollen stattfinden aktuell, weil sich DFB und die Landesverbände da über die Finanzierung streiten. Und was natürlich auch ein ziemlich krasses Thema ist, erstmal so an sich. Und ja, das hat dann leider mit Kick-Ass-Off-Mar nicht funktioniert.
Okay, dann haben wir Ärztespieler-Vereide. Lass uns noch kurz über die Kultur sprechen, in der ja auch der Fußball stattfindet. Und da sind ja auch Journalistinnen und Journalisten und ich glaube auch die Zuschauer dann noch mal wichtig. Glaubt ihr denn, dass auf der Seite jetzt zum Beispiel der Berichterstatterinnen und Berichterstatter da schon das richtige Maß gefunden wird an Heldenverehrung für jemanden, der sich durchbeißt in einem Spiel und eine außergewöhnliche sportliche Leistung erzeugt und Verständnis für Schwäche?
Ja, Thema moderne Gladiatoren. Ist ja ganz klar, dass das auch eine Rolle spielt, wo man dann häufig immer wieder von dieser Heldenverehrung spricht und der XY hat sich durchgebissen oder XY hat wie ein Mann gespielt. Wir müssen wieder wie Männer spielen und so weiter. Diese ganzen unsäglichen Aussagen gibt es ja häufiger auf Pressekonferenzen zu hören, teilweise auch von Verantwortlichen im Fußballbetrieb. Das zeigt dann immer schon das auf, was Neven Subotic im Gespräch mit uns benannt hat. Das ist diese harte Jungs-Mentalität, die vorherrscht. Das heißt, du sollst eigentlich gar keine Schwächen zeigen. Du sollst nicht proaktiv zum Arzt gehen und sagen, ich habe hier ein leichtes Ziehen und will heute nicht trainieren. Das wird automatisch als Schwäche ausgelegt in diesem System. Da spielen natürlich auch die Medien eine Rolle. Das ist ja keine Frage. Wir hatten einen Fall in der Bundesliga-Saison, in der aktuellen Ende Oktober. Borussia Dortmund spielt gegen Borussia Mönchengladbach. Das war ein ziemliches Spitzenspiel damals. Es ging um die Tabellenführung, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Also wirklich zwei der positiven Beispiele in dieser Bundesliga-Saison, was Fußball angeht. Da hatten wir auf der einen Seite Stefan Leiner, Rechtsverteidiger, hat gespielt, obwohl er sich, ich glaube, 13 Tage vorher ein Band in der Kapsel im Spongelenk gerissen hatte, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Er hat aber 13 Tage später dann gegen Dortmund wieder gespielt und war mit der beste Mann auf dem Platz aus Gladbacher Sicht. Dann hat Marco Rose, der Gladbacher Trainer, im Nachgang der Partie gesagt, ja, das ist nicht selbstverständlich, dass er hier spielt. Das zeigt aber, was der Junge für eine Einstellung hat. Ich kenne jetzt den medizinischen Befund nicht genau. Ich bin mir auch da jetzt erst mal benefit of doubt für die medizinische Abteilung von Borussia München-Gladbach, dass sie den entsprechend behandelt haben, den Stefan Leiner, und dass eben sicher war, dass nicht so viel passieren kann. Aber das ist eben nur ein Beispiel, was eben dann zeigt, dass auch proaktiv damit umgegangen wird, gesagt wird, der hat sich in den Dienst der Mannschaft gestellt, obwohl er verletzt ist bzw. Und lustigerweise, auf der anderen Seite, Marco Reus, der dann später auch das Siegtor geschossen hat, war erkältet, hat gespielt mit einem Infekt, der ihn dann drei Tage später daran ging, in der Champions-Seek zu spielen. Und auch da, erstmal wieder medizinische Abteilung Borussia Dortmund, können wir davon ausgehen, dass sie das medizinisch soweit abgeklärt haben, dass es kein Risiko für Marco Reus war, zu spielen. Aber auch da gab es dann eben die Social-Media-Abteilung von Borussia Dortmund, die das abgefeiert hat, das Marco Reus gespielt hat, trotz Erkältung. Und auch das Siegtor dann geschossen hat. Und bei Twitter war es dann so, dass dann darunter auch die Kommentare kamen von Leuten, ja, was soll das denn für ein Vorbild für Kinder sein? Und ich hatte jetzt, da gab es jemand, der geschrieben hatte, ja, bei uns ist jemand auf dem Spielfeld umgekippt wegen genau so was, Gefahr, Herzmuskelentzündung und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt, diese Mentalität erstmal zu durchbrechen, ist, glaube ich, ein ganz, ganz langer Weg.
Man, da müssen wir selbst uns ja auch kritisch hinterfragen, weil man ist ja Teil des Spektakls. Und gleichzeitig ist es ja auch, ja, wie soll man einen Zuschauer eines Sportereignisses dafür begeistern, wenn jemand etwas nicht tut, wenn er nicht spielt oder wenn er sich nicht durchbeißt, wenn er sich eben auswechseln lässt. Das ist ja auch, das scheint ja auch irgendwie fast unmöglich zu sein, wie man diese Kultur da anschieben kann, weil es eben einfach so ein wichtiger Teil des Leistungssports ist, dass wir eben etwas in den Sportlern sehen, was wir nicht so leisten im Stande wären. Und dann ist immer derjenige mit dem völlig zerrissenen Trikot, der keinen geraden Satz mehr rausbringt, ist für uns beeindruckender, als derjenige, der nach dem Spiel noch aussieht wie vor dem Spiel. Das wird dann eher kritisiert.
Total, bei der Grundsatz-Gladiatoren-Debatte, wie schnell muss jemand den Berg hochfahren? Oder wie lange muss jemand laufen können in der Verlängerung? Wie schnell und wie oft noch laufen können in der Verlängerung?
Ja, genau. Und ich sehe da ehrlich gesagt auch irgendwie wenig Möglichkeit, das zu verändern. Also langfristig kann sich da graduell vielleicht etwas verändern. Aber wenn wir eben, also genau dieses Thema ist ja ein spannendes, was müsste sich denn verändern jetzt im Leistungssport, um Spieler zu schützen und aber eben auch um die Öffentlichkeit, Vereine und andere Beteiligte für dieses Thema zu sensibilisieren? Und da sehe ich ehrlich gesagt bei den Zuschauern, das ist für mich so das letzte Glied in der Kette. Und da habe ich auch gar nicht so die große Hoffnung, ähnlich wie leider auch bei Journalistinnen und Journalisten, dass sich da wirklich langfristig etwas verändert. Seid ihr da ähnlich pessimistisch?
Ja, ich sehe das genauso. Also ich glaube, was sich ändern kann, ist, dass es insgesamt mehr, auch im Profibereich, mehr Aufklärung einfach gibt, dass zumindest einmal auf den Tisch gelegt wird. Das sind die potenziellen Folgen, wenn du es übertreibst. Das, glaube ich, ist noch nicht genügend. Das kann sich verändern. Und was ich viel wichtiger finde, ist dann die Übertragung auf den breiten Sport, auf den Amateurbereich, dass die Vorbildfunktion, die viele Fußballer in Zukunft wahrscheinlich auch nicht gerecht werden oder werden können, dass zumindest dann das nicht übertragen und angenommen wird im Amateurbereich, in dem man auch denkt, das ist doch irgendwie normal und ich greife regelmäßig Tabletten, dort wird das auch getan. Oder das ist sozusagen diese Harte-Jungs-Mentalität, die ich auch in meinem Bereich weiterleben kann. Ich glaube, da kann man tatsächlich was verändern. Ich wollte jetzt überleiten.
Ich möchte noch eine kurze Frage stellen zu den Veränderungen, weil wir es vorher gestreift haben. Wie realistisch ist es denn, dass Schmerzmittel in einer missbräuchlichen Form auf die Doping-Liste kommt? Ich wurde kurz hellhörig, als ihr gesagt habt, es gab den Vorschlag schon vor zehn Jahren mal.
Wir haben die WADA auch dazu befragt. Die bleibt bei ihrer aktuellen Position, vor der Veröffentlichung zumindest, dass sie daran jetzt erst mal nichts ändern. Bei der WADA wäre der normale Ablauf, dass sie, bevor sie etwas verbieten, erst mal Substanzen oder Methoden auf eine Monitoring-Liste setzen. Dann gibt es quasi so eine längere Entscheidungsphase. Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer ein Jahr dauert und auch mal länger sein kann, wo dann wirklich genauer geschaut wird und geprüft wird, ob da was Richtung Verbot gehen sollte. Manchmal geht es auch ganz schnell, wenn es so ganz neue Doping-Sachen sind. Das muss nicht immer ein sehr langer Ablauf sein. Sie sind ja eh schon langsam genug als Dopingjäger, Anti-Dopingjäger. Aber das wäre jetzt so der normale Weg, wenn es um so eine Kunstheitsdebatte geht. Und da den Punkt haben wir noch nicht erreicht. Deswegen, ich schätze jetzt die Chancen heute Montagabend vor der Veröffentlichung als erst mal gering an. Und dann warten wir mal ab, was in ein paar Tagen die Debatte weitergeht. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, ist es eine deutsche Debatte oder eine internationale? Damit die WADA sich das auch irgendwie genauer anschaut, ist das nur eine Fußballdebatte oder eine Debatte, die es auch in anderen Sportarten sehr wichtig ist. Den zweiten Punkt kann man relativ schnell beantworten. Natürlich ist es kein fußballsterezifisches Thema. Wenn man jetzt nur an Handball, Rugby und Co. denkt, da gibt es auch Forschung zu. Über leichter Lidik gibt es auch Studien konkret zum Schmerzblühe, Konsum bei leichter Lidik-Turnieren, die auf ähnliche Ergebnisse kommen. Dann ist das natürlich kein spezifisches Fußballthema. Aber so die erste Frage, wie global wird diskutiert, davon hängt glaube ich sehr viel ab, ob die WADA extra Gremien startet oder irgendwelche Arbeitsgruppen sich damit näher beschäftigen.
Habt ihr euch deshalb auch auf den Fußball fokussiert, weil es hier in Deutschland einfach der Sport ist, anhand dessen man am besten auch eine breitgeführte Debatte los treten kann?
Also zum Arne, sorry, dass jetzt die Fragen beantwortet, wir spielen gleich wieder mehr Ping-Pong. Also das ist erstmal historisch bedingt, weil wir am Anfang gesagt haben, so jetzt wollen wir mal den Fußball richtig anschauen, was sozusagen medizinisch da los ist, was wir auch weiterhin sagen. Aber dadurch sind wir irgendwann ja zu dem ersten Aufschlag Schmerzbildel gekommen. Das Zweite ist aber genau das. Also ich finde, mit grad was medizinische Themen und Gesundheitsthemen betrifft, wird dafür, dass der Sport hat so groß in Deutschland, wird einfach viel zu wenig dieses Thema noch über dieses Thema berichtet und darüber diskutiert. Also da geht es ja auch um die ganzen anderen Randthemen, also mit Corona gerade natürlich ganz, ganz aktuell. Aber was das Thema Kopfverletzung betrifft, ja, und auch noch ganz andere Debatten, auch psychologische Themen und so. Ich finde das noch so klein im Fußball dafür, dass so ein Riesensportart bei uns ist, taucht das immer nur so punktuell rund um irgendwelche Ereignisse mal auf und dann ist es wieder gefühlt ganz schön schnell weg. Und das wollen wir zumindest mal versuchen, bei dem Thema das einmal groß anzufassen, jetzt auch nicht so anekdotisch, indem sich irgendwie zwei, drei Leute äußern und dann ist es nach einem Tag wieder vorbei, sondern ein bisschen größer in der Hoffnung, dass es jetzt auch zumindest mal eine Debatte zum Thema gibt.
Und da habt ihr ja mit eurer Recherche dann eben auch den Fokus noch erweitert, indem ihr eben nicht nur auf den Leistungssport guckt, sondern das Thema auch noch näher an die Menschen ranholt, beziehungsweise eigentlich den Scheinwerfer dorthin leuchten lasst, wo das Thema schon ist, nämlich auch im Freizeitsport. Was sind denn da eure Erkenntnisse? Wie groß ist das Problem Schmerzmittelmissbrauch im Breitensport?
Auch da haben wir natürlich versucht, das Ganze erstmal aus unserer Perspektive so einzugrenzen, dass wir das einigermaßen fassbar machen können und eben genau diese Datengrundlage schaffen, damit wir einigermaßen argumentieren können, weil natürlich hatte man im Vorfeld immer gehört, Schmerzmittel ist beim Handball ein wahnsinniges Problem. Es gibt Leute, die Marathons gelaufen sind und im Vorfeld Schmerzmittel genommen haben, aber das war jetzt keine systemische und breit angelegte Recherche. Und wir haben eben auch versucht, undockend an das, was wir für den Profibereich schon recherchiert hatten, eine Umfrage aufzusetzen, die wir mit Hilfe des Crowd-Newsrooms, einer Plattform von Correctiv, dann durchgeführt haben. Und diese Umfrage hatte eben zum Ziel herauszufinden, welche Rolle Schmerzmittel im Amateurfußball spielen. Das heißt, wir haben im Zeitraum zwischen Dezember 2019 und März 2020 diese Umfrage offen beworben, über die verschiedenen Wege, über Social Media, über proaktives Anschreiben von Vereinsvertreterinnen und Vereinsvertretern, sodass wir jetzt einigermaßen umreißen können, welche Rolle das Ganze spielt.
Auch über den Rasenfunk. Das ist der eine Punkt, wo ein ganz kleines Teilchen der Rasenfunk auch vielleicht geholfen hat.
Wir haben es sogar gesehen. Wir haben es sogar in den Daten gesehen.
Ehrlich?
Als die Sendung rausging. Nein, wirklich.
Sauber, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mensch, da bin ich jetzt richtig stolz.
Sehr gut.
Gute Community.
Das ist nämlich genau das Ding. Solche Sachen funktionieren eben nur, wenn sich die Leute daran beteiligen und wenn die Leute Journalismus in der Form dann unterstützen und sagen, okay, ich nehme jetzt die fünf Minuten und klicke das mal an und gehe das durch und so. Also daher nochmal ein dickes Dankeschön. Und wir haben dann eben am Ende es geschafft, unser Gesetzesziel auch zu erreichen. Und das Gesetzesziel waren 1000 Teilnehmende. Und als wir dann die Auswertung begonnen haben, das war irgendwann im März, haben wir bei einem Stand von 1142 Teilnehmenden und dementsprechend dann auch antworten, erstmal für uns einen Break gemacht und gesagt, okay, das werden wir jetzt mal aus. Diese Umfrage ist immer noch offen. Das heißt, da kann man sich immer noch daran beteiligen und seine Ergebnisse quasi mit uns teilen. Und ich denke, Max, das wirst du in den Show-Notes dann nochmal...
Es soll den nächsten Rasenfunk-Spike geben. Liebe Leute, ich möchte das nochmal in den Daten sehen können, dass da jetzt Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer teilgenommen haben. Vor allem gerne auch Hörerinnen. Ich habe gesehen, die prozentuale Beteilung weiblicher Fußballer war dann doch noch relativ gering mit 4% gerundet.
Überschaubar, ja. Und das ist allgemein auch ein Thema, was wir fairerweise jetzt mal sagen müssen, dass wir nicht in der umfassenden Form haben bearbeiten können, wie jetzt im Männerbereich, weil auch im Frauenfußball ist das natürlich ein Thema. Keine Frage. Also wir haben auch mit Frauenfußballern gesprochen, auch ehemalige Profis, ehemalige bekannte Figuren. Aber dadurch, dass eben niemand von ihnen bereit war, vor die Kamera zu gehen oder sich offen dazu zu äußern, war dann für uns die Grundlage eben relativ gering, dann zu sagen, wir machen jetzt auch einen Text dazu. Aber das ist natürlich genauso relevant und ich denke, auch genauso ein Problem.
Und was waren...
Ein kurzer Break-Up, bevor jetzt zu den Ergebnissen kommt. Wir wollen ja auch ein bisschen Making-of machen, glaube ich, in dem Podcast. Was ich sehr unterhaltsam fand, war diese Zeit, als wir versucht haben, die Umfrage beizustreuen. Wir haben versucht, mit sehr händischer Arbeit, also insgesamt sind wir, wie viele Leute waren wir eigentlich im Team? Das haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt. Ich glaube, acht Leute, die regelmäßig mitgearbeitet haben. Das Team ist mittlerweile noch deutlich größer geworden in der ganzen Produktionsphase. Aber an der Zeit haben wir uns die Bundesländer aufgeteilt und möglichst viele Club-Adressen versucht, erst mal was zu bekommen. Die ganzen Leute über WhatsApp dann angeschrieben. Also wirklich sehr, sehr händisch. Da waren sehr unterhaltsame Gespräche dabei aus ganz Deutschland. Teilweise hat ein Kontakt sehr lange gedauert, weil man dann öfters ins Gespräch gekommen ist und eigentlich nur wollte, dass im Verein mal kurz diese Obfrage gestreut wird in der schnellen WhatsApp-Nachricht. Bei vielen Vereinen kamen natürlich auch gar nicht zurück, aber allein das hat schon wieder Folgekontakte eröffnet. Und den einen oder anderen werden wir wahrscheinlich morgen auch nochmal kontaktieren und sagen, es gibt jetzt übrigens die Ergebnisse. Und falls irgendwer von diesen Personen auch den Rasenfunk hört, was ich jetzt sehr wahrscheinlich finde, dann verzeiht bitte, dass morgen noch mal eine Nachricht rausgeht. Also, nee, heute rausgingen. Und ihr noch mal eine E-Mail oder eine WhatsApp-Nachricht vielleicht von uns bekommen habt. Schaut euch doch bitte dann trotzdem noch mal die Ergebnisse an. Danach werden wir uns nie wieder melden.
Ja, wer weiß, wer weiß. Ich denke ja, man will ja dann auch wissen, wie die Ergebnisse dieser Studie gewonnen sind. Wenn man das Interesse hatte, daran hatte mitzumachen, dann interessieren einen auch die Ergebnisse, die ihr unter anderem über WhatsApp-Nachrichten eingesammelt habt. Ich ziehe meinen Hut vor euch. Was sind denn dann die Ergebnisse?
So, greifen wir das erstmal so ein bisschen ab, was jetzt so die Zielgruppe war, die wir erreicht haben. Max hat es eben schon gesagt, das waren natürlich zu 95% Männer und eben zu 80% oder etwas mehr als 80% Männer im Alter von 18 bis 35. Das heißt, genau die Zielgruppe, die man auch erwarten kann, eben Männer, die im Amateurbereich spielen. Wir können jetzt da chronologisch erstmal durchgehen, was die wichtigsten Ergebnisse waren. Die wichtigste Frage ist natürlich, wie viel Prozent von diesen Antworten haben angegeben, dass sie Schmerzmittel genommen haben? Da sind wir bei 80. Das heißt, 8 von 10 Spielern haben angegeben, dass sie im Laufe ihrer Fußballkarriere Schmerzmittel genommen haben. Wir haben versucht, das ein bisschen einzugrenzen, was die Häufigkeit angeht. Da haben wir mehr als ein Drittel der Spieler, die mehrmals pro Saison Schmerzmittel einnehmen. Das heißt mehrfach in einer Saison. Dann haben wir auch einen Bereich, der sich auf einen Zeitraum in einem Monat bezieht. Auch da haben wir relativ deutliche Ergebnisse bekommen, sodass man sagen kann, dass fast 20 % mindestens einmal im Monat bzw. auch noch mehr Schmerzmittel vor jedem Training, vor jedem Spiel aufnehmen. Die Dokumente und die Auswertungen stellen wir auch zur Verfügung. Das ist dann eben eine Art und Weise, wie man das interpretiert, in welchem zeitlichen Korridor.
Man muss dazusagen, es ist statistisch gesehen keine Repräsentative. Das zeigt vielleicht schon die Aufteilung zwischen Frauen und Männern, dass es schwierig ist, eine Repräsentativität herzustellen. Aber es ist trotzdem aussagekräftig, wenn man sagen kann, z.B. aufgerundet 2% nehmen vor jedem Training Schmerzmittel zu sich und immerhin noch 7% vor jedem Spiel. Wenn wir darüber sprechen, dass das große Problem vor allem eine Überdosierung und eine Regelmäßigkeit im Nehmen ist, dann sieht man da schon, das ist unter der Klammer nicht repräsentativ trotzdem weit verbreitet im Freizeitsport. Und vielleicht auch weiter, als man es vermutet hätte.
Genau, und die Übertragung auf die gesamte Anzahl an Menschen, die in Deutschland im Verein Fußball spielen, die ist rein wissenschaftlich gesehen nicht zulässig. Das ist schon auch ein Ding. Es war keine wissenschaftliche Studie, das möchte ich betonen. Aber es hat eben auch in der Wissenschaft bisher keine Erhebung dieser Art gegeben, sodass jetzt auch schon von verschiedenen Institutionen Leute an uns herangetreten sind, die dann auch morgen bzw. heute diese Datengrundlage bekommen, sodass sie dann auch daraufhin sich dem Ganzen aus einer wissenschaftlichen Perspektive nähern können. Und wir haben eben dann auch festgestellt, in Bezug auf die Details zu den Schmerzmitteln, dass eben Ibuprofen die Substanz ist, die am häufigsten genommen wird. Und wir haben dann auch versucht, uns da schon ein bisschen einzugrenzen, dass wir das eben nach Marktsegment dann auch anbieten, sodass dann eben Mehrverantworten auch möglich waren. Aber da hat sich immer herausgestellt, dass Ibuprofen das Schmerzmittel ist, das am häufigsten genommen wurde. Und interessanterweise haben wir dann dort auch festgestellt, dass Opioide auch von Amateurfußballern genommen worden sind, dafür, dass sie eben am Wochenende im Amateurfußball spielen können, was für uns natürlich schon alarmierend war, als wir das gesehen haben.
Und Opioide sind Betäubungsmittel, kann man das so generell sagen?
Genau, man muss so ein bisschen unterscheiden. Ich glaube, Opioide sind ja Betäubungsmittel. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die nach offizieller Definition dann nur die starken so heißen. Aber was genau wichtig ist, ist die Unterscheidung. Es gibt sozusagen diese Unterscheidungen. Und Opioide kennt man, glaube ich, hauptsächlich, wenn man sich ein bisschen mit dem Thema beschäftigt, durch die Opioidsituation in den USA, wo viele Menschen ja täglich an einer Überdosis an Opioiden sterben. Und daran erkennt man, glaube ich, schon, dass das eine ganz andere Hausnummer ist. Opioide kommen erst mal daher, dass das einfach noch mal in der Schmerztherapie eine weitere Stufe ist, wenn die klassischen Schmerzmittel nicht wirken. Man spricht von so einem Dreistufensystem. Dann ist das, glaube ich, Stufe 2 erst mal, dass man die Opioide ergibt. Das betrifft vor allem Krebspatienten nach schweren OPs. Also Leute, wo es so richtig um Schmerzen geht und um schwere Schmerztherapien. Daher kommen die eigentlich. So jetzt ist die Frage, warum spielt das irgendeiner Form der Amateurfußballer eine Rolle? Also ich glaube, wenn ich diese Zahl noch nicht im Kopf habe, die kann man aber auch alle dann auf unserer Webseite genauer nachlesen und sich selber noch mal korrigieren. Ich würde sagen, zehn Amateurfußballerinnen und Fußballer hatten angegeben, dass sie auch Opioide genommen haben für den Sport. Und da haben uns total die Details sofort interessiert, als wir das gelesen haben. Weil wir da mehrere Anschlussfragen hatten. Also ist das nur entstanden, weil sie irgendwie selber sonst andere Gesundheitsprobleme hatten oder eben irgendeine OP oder was anderes. Und das ist nur ein bisschen missverständlich. Oder haben sie das tatsächlich für den Fußball genommen? Wenn sie das für den Fußball genommen haben, wie sind sie da drangekommen? Weil Opioide kriegt man nur verschrieben. Also muss man das entweder spielt da irgendwer mit einem Arzt zusammen oder hat irgendwo noch was übrig oder hat andere Quellen, wo er das herbekommt. Und wenn es dort Kontakt an Möglichkeiten gab, dann haben wir diese Personen versucht direkt anzurufen oder mit denen zu schreiben.
Und da gibt es eben nochmal ganz andere Gefahren. Jetzt waren das ja immerhin Gott sei Dank von euren Teilnehmenden nur zehn. Gott sei Dank. Was ich aber interessant finde an dieser Studie ist eben nicht nur, dass man so ein bisschen die Dimensionen erforschen kann, sondern ihr habt auch nach den Gründen gefragt, warum die Schmerzmittel genommen werden. Haben euch da die Ergebnisse überrascht? Könnt ihr das mal kurz für die Hörerinnen und Hörern vortragen und eure Einschätzung dazu abgeben?
Das ist jetzt Arne's Bühne.
Natürlich war das überraschend. Wir haben nochmal auch als Disclaimer verschiedene Punkte angegeben, fünf an der Zahl. Und da waren auch mehrfach Antworten möglich. Und wir haben eben das, was wir vorher wussten, kondensiert in eben diese fünf Punkte. Ich nenne sie mal kurz Schmerzen aus Verletzung lindern, Belastbarkeit nach Krankheit, Verletzung erhöhen, um den Kopf freizuhaben und sich sicher zu fühlen, Leistung steigern und Punkt fünf, keine konkreten Ziele, ich nahm sie aus Routine. Das heißt, dort konnten die Leute angeben mit mehrfach Antworten, was die Gründe waren für ihre Schmerzmitteleinnahme. Und wir haben dann 1525 Antworten bekommen. Und von diesen 1525 Antworten beziehen sich 56,7 Prozent darauf, dass Schmerzen gelindert werden sollen. Da kann man erst mal sagen, okay, Schmerzen sollen durch Schmerzmittel gelindert werden, alles klar. Aber das sind nur 57 Prozent aufgerundet. Und dann ist für uns die Frage gewesen, was ist denn mit den anderen 40 Prozent? Also was ist mit den Menschen, die sagen, sie wollen ihre Belastbarkeit nach einer Verletzung erhöhen beispielsweise, oder die sagen, ich nehme Schmerzmittel, damit ich mit freiem Kopf in das Spiel gehen kann. Das dient ja nicht dem eigentlichen Zweck, den Schmerzmittel haben, Schmerzen zu lindern, sondern das ist dann ein Punkt, wo wir sagen können, dass es der Bereich, der missbräuchlich ist. Und dass fünf Prozent ganz offen sagen, sie wollen ihre Leistung steigern, das ist natürlich immens beunruhigend. Und das ist auch eine Sache, die dann bei dem Gespräch, was wir zusammen mit der ARD-Dopingredaktion mit Fritz Keller geführt haben, aufgekommen ist. Als er sich diese Ergebnisse angeschaut hat, da war er dann einigermaßen schockiert und betroffen und überrascht. Denn das ist natürlich schon erstaunlich, dass vier von zehn Leuten, beziehungsweise, nee, muss man anders formulieren, aber dass 40 Prozent sich nicht darauf beziehen, auf den eigentlichen Zweck, dass Schmerzen gelindert werden sollen. Das ist dann für den Amateurfußball schon ein alarmierendes Ergebnis, finde ich.
Da können wir vielleicht an der Stelle dann mal kurz reinhören, weil du es gerade angesprochen hast. Ihr habt mir den O-Ton auch mitgebracht von der ARD-Dopingredaktion. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Das war die Reaktion von Fritz Keller.
Ich muss echt sagen, dass ich schon etwas betroffen habe. Müssen wir unbedingt an unsere Landesverbände gehen und über Fußballlehrer, über Trainer einfach eine Sensibilisierung hinkriegen. Das ist ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Problem. Ich werde das aber sofort überprüfen. Und einfach auch im Sinne der Gesunderhaltung unserer Sportlerinnen und Sportler einfach das kommunizieren müssen.
Wie hat denn Fritz Keller und seine Reaktion auf euch und die Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Recherche gewirkt?
Also wir beide waren auch bei dem Dreh jetzt nicht dabei. Wir haben aber auch danach mit dem DFB noch weiter Kontakt gehabt. Deswegen würde ich das sozusagen in der Gesamtsicht beantworten. Was wir jetzt erstmal interessant fanden als Signal ist, dass das erstmal Fritz Keller dadurch gezeigt hat, noch insgesamt der DFB und seine Reaktion, dass sie die Ergebnisse durchaus ernst nehmen. Fritz Keller hat ja selber davon gesprochen, dass er irgendwie schockiert ist. Ich habe ihn vorher noch nicht so in seinen Reaktionen erlebt. Ich hatte einen schlechten Vergleich. Aber jetzt so mit der Corona-Debatte oder der Rassismus-Debatte hat er sich auch in anderen Positionen noch geäußert. Er scheint ja schon jemand beim DFB zu sein, der sich auch zu ethischen Themen schnell äußert und Positionen bezieht, bevor dann irgendwann der DFB zu Sachen, ob man eine Pressemitteilung rausgibt oder irgendwelche großen Aktionen darum macht. Das ist ja auch so gedacht in der neuen Organigrammstruktur des DFB, dass sie sozusagen die Präsidentenamt geschafft haben, wo jemand so ein Sprachrohr ist für so ethische Themen. Und in dem Rahmen würde ich ihn jetzt mal einordnen. Und das fand ich schon interessant, das fand ich auch authentisch in dem Videomaterial, was wir gesehen haben, das erstmal auch so überrascht ist, dass es im Amateurfußball besonders so ein Problem ist. Jetzt muss man insgesamt zählen. Das sind jetzt erstmal sozusagen Aussagen, die halbwegs spontan von ihm gekommen sind. Und für uns ist jetzt die spannende Frage, wie geht das jetzt weiter, was heißt denn das jetzt, wenn der DFB-Präsident sagt, wir werden uns das auf jeden Fall anschauen, wir werden da was mit Anführungsstrichen untersuchen. Was sind die nächsten Schritte? Wir haben dazu mit dem DFB jetzt nochmal geschrieben, sie sind an zwei Stellen konkreter geworden, indem sie gesagt haben, sie wollen jetzt erst mal eine Videoschulung starten mit einem Schmerzmittel-Experten, der beim DFB schon ganz oft oder auch insgesamt beim Thema Erscheinung getreten ist. Toni Graf Baumann heißt der Mann, wenn man den mal googelt und Fußball eingibt, dann sieht man auch, dass in was für allen möglichen Ämtern, der schon in dem Bereich unterwegs war, also den haben wir auch persönlich mal getroffen. So ist es bei langen Recherchen, da trifft man irgendwann immer auf alle Leute, die man dann irgendwo anders auch schon mal gehört hat. Das ist jetzt sozusagen ein schneller Schritt. Auch da muss man schauen, was macht er konkret und wie sieht so etwas aus, Video-Schulung. Es gibt ja relativ viele Vereine in Deutschland. Oder ist das was, sozusagen Link, der dann rumgeschickt wird und wie wird er angenommen. Eine zweite Sache, die sie gesagt haben, ist, dass sie mit der Anhilfe auf die Sprünge, Bundeszentrale für... Gesundheitliche Aufklärung. Genau, die Gespräche, die ich mit ihnen suchen möchte, zum Thema Sucht und Schmerzmittelmissbrauch im Amateurfußball. Auch da muss man jetzt wieder beobachten, was das konkret heißt. Aber ich finde das jetzt erstmal eine interessante Basis. Und jetzt heißt es, journalistisch und insgesamt dran zu bleiben und zu beobachten, was dann die konkreten Schritte sind.
Also das ist dann der DFB als Zuständiger für den Breitensport, zumindest für den in Verbänden organisierten Breitensport. Ihr habt auch in dem Bereich, und das finde ich, macht die Recherche dann auch plastisch, habt ihr Beispiele herausgesucht, habt Interviews geführt mit Menschen, die auch mit euch dann sprechen wollten. Es gab eine Zahl, die hat mich erst nicht überrascht in eurer Untersuchung und dann aber irgendwie schon, nämlich die Frage, hast du dich mit den möglichen Nebenwirkungen von Schmerzmitteln, die du genommen hast, auseinandergesetzt? Und da haben 66 Prozent gesagt, nein, ich habe mich nicht damit auseinandergesetzt. Und erst dachte ich mir, ich lese mir ja auch nicht jeden Beipackzettel durch. Aber als ich das dann noch mal so abgeglichen habe mit den Prozentzahlen, die wir vorher angesprochen haben, wie viele dann regelmäßig Schmerzmittel nehmen und wie viele auch aus gar nicht mehr schmerzinduzierten Gründen vielleicht heraus Schmerzmittel nehmen, da fand ich das dann doch sehr bedenklich und hatte auch das Gefühl, das ist doch so das klassische Ergebnis, was man bekommt, auch bei aller Nichtrepräsentativität und so weiter, also schon mitdenken, aber dennoch ist das klassische Ergebnis, was man nur dann bekommt, wenn auch gar kein Bewusstsein für ein Thema vorhanden ist, in einer breiten Gesellschaftsschicht.
Das ist, glaube ich, der zentrale Befund. Also das kann man auch schon sagen, dass das für uns das war, was wir als zentrales Ergebnis rausgenommen haben aus den ganzen Monaten, in denen wir die Umfrage aufgesetzt hatten, in dem wir zwischendurch immer ausgewertet haben und dann auch am Ende. Also diese Schnittmenge an den Leuten, die regelmäßig Schmerzmittel nehmen und die sich nicht mit Nebenwirkungen auseinandersetzen, die ist immens hoch. Und das ist natürlich für den DFB dann auch ein Thema, keine Frage.
Und um auch da nochmal ein Beispiel zu bringen, damit es ein bisschen konkreter wird, ich erzähle jetzt die ganze Geschichte, den Rest kann man auch noch ein bisschen nachlesen, aber wir haben mit einem Fußballer relativ oft gesprochen aus dem Sauerland, ein Amateurspieler, Felix Lennepaar, der sich auch fotografieren lassen und offen darüber spricht, an dem genau diese ganzen Themen total deutlich werden, also dann sieht man vielleicht auch die Umfrage, diese abstrakten Zahlen nochmal so, da kann man die ein bisschen konkreter verstehen, wie das nach Praxis, wie zumindestens beispielhaft aussehen kann. Das ist jemand, der auch regelmäßig mit Ibuprofen angefangen hat, irgendwann haben die Ibus dann nicht mehr gewirkt, also die Schmerzen blieben, dann hat er die Dosierung erhöht, in mehreren Schritten, irgendwann waren es dann sozusagen nicht mal die 400er, sondern die 800er, das hatten wir ja schon vor als Thema, da ging es immer weiter. Bei dem gab es dann eben den Übergang, dass er, obwohl er zu dem Zeitpunkt schon gemerkt hat, dass seine Leberwerte nicht mehr in Ordnung sind, er sich oft auch ganz schön schlapp führt, was sozusagen auf die Leberwerte zurückführbar sein kann, hat er es nicht geschafft, damit aufzuhören, sondern hat dann noch von Mitspielern ein Opioid, ein synthetisches Tiledin in dem Fall, angeboten bekommen. Da war er so gerade im Übergang von der zweiten zur ersten Mannschaft und hat dann gesagt, dann probiere es damit und hat sich dann besser gefühlt. Da waren die Schmerzen dann erstmal da wieder weg. Das Problem ist, dass er genau dann in der Zeit abhängig geworden ist und ein halbes Jahr das dann genommen hat und teilweise sogar mit nach Hause genommen hat und täglich genommen hat in der Hochzeit. Da ging es dann sozusagen komplett weg. Da war der Fußball dann tatsächlich durch den Fußball ging es los als Einstiegsdroge Ibuprofen, was natürlich nicht als Droge in dem Sinne zu werten ist, aber das war dann der kleine Übergang von höherer Dosierung bis zu härteren Mitteln. Und bei ihm ist es so, wir haben sehr oft miteinander gesprochen in den letzten Monaten, dass ihn das bis heute beeinträchtigt, sein Leben, weil er zwischendurch immer wieder dieses Problem hat, dass er total fertig ist, dann nur noch auf der Couch rumliegen kann und nicht mehr in der Form aktiv sein kann in solchen Phasen, wie er sich normalerweise in seinem Alter sein müsste. Er spielt auch keinen Fußball mehr, das muss er eh schon aufgeben, vor ein paar Jahren. Und es gab auch zwei Situationen in seinem Leben, wo er tatsächlich auch richtig ernst wurde, wo er einmal umgekippt ist und dann bewusst auf dem Platz lag. Auch da wird man jetzt im Endeffekt nie nachweisen können, lag es an den Tiledin, was er damals direkt vom Spiel genommen hat. Eine andere Situation war, wo es bei ihm nochmal richtig geknallt hat und er, wie viel war es? Ich glaube, eineinhalb Liter Blut, in kurzer Zeit im Oberschenkel sich gesammelt hat, weil er immer wieder nicht aufhören konnte. Und dann hat der Körper eigentlich ziemlich viele Signale gesendet. Über die Jahre. Ich brauch mal eine Pause. Und mit den Schmerzbitteln hat er sich diese Pause nicht genommen, sondern weitergemacht. Jetzt hab ich ja doch fast die ganze Geschichte schon erzählt.
Lest sie bitte trotzdem. Es ist wirklich interessant. Ich kannte ja Tiledin bisher nur von Kraftklub. Da merkt man vielleicht, dass ich dann doch in meiner eigenen Blasse auch lebe. Eine Sache aus dem Artikel will ich aber trotzdem noch sagen. Lest ihn aber bitte trotzdem. Wenn jetzt vielleicht jemand da draußen gedacht hat, naja gut, der wird in irgendeinem 20.000 Einwohner-Stadt gespielt haben, und da ging es dann um den Aufstieg in die Bayern- oder Baden-Württemberg- oder na gut, war ja Sauerland-Liga. Heißt nicht so, ist mir schon klar. Ne, der kommt aus einem Dorf mit 200 Einwohnern. Und das war das, was mich so gepackt hat, weil ich halt auch aus solchen Käffern komme. Und ich auch weiß, wie wichtig da der Fußball ist. Und das war bei mir tatsächlich auch einer der Gründe, warum ich, als ich dann mein Abi gemacht habe, aufgehört habe, in der ersten Mannschaft zu spielen, freiwillig. Weil sich da binnen sechs Wochen, glaube ich, haben sich da vier Spieler schlimmer verletzt. Die waren alle auch in Ausbildung. Also für die war das auch, da gab es auch zum Teil, einer von denen war Schreiner, glaube ich, der hätte gar nicht Fußball spielen dürfen. Das stand bei ihm im Arbeitsvertrag. Weil der Chef quasi schon wusste, die hauen sich immer beim Fußball die Knochen kaputt. Und es ging quasi darum, ob man vielleicht aus der untersten Bezirksklasse vielleicht in die vorletzte Bezirksklasse aussteigt. Und selbst das war völlig unrealistisch, wenn ihr mich fragt, wenn man sich so die Gegner angeguckt hat. Das war nur meine Meinung. Und ich habe quasi gesehen, wie die aus diesem falschen Ehrgeiz heraus sich kaputt gemacht haben und das dann auch selber auch... Also für alle Beteiligten ist das dann gefährlich. Das kennt man ja, wenn da gebeuzt wird auf dem Fußballplatz, kannst dich auch erwischen. Und deswegen bin ich dann freiwillig in die 2. Mannschaft gegangen. Also das Verständnis war gering an dieser Stelle, um das so zu sagen. Und das hat mich aber so gepackt, dass das quasi auf dieser kleinen Ebene stattfindet. Und ich weiß, wie wichtig Fußball da ist. Und ich weiß auch, wie toll sich das anfühlt. Wenn wir das Derby gewonnen haben gegen den Nachbarort, mit dem inzwischen natürlich längst fusioniert wurde, weil es gibt ja keine Fußballspieler mehr und so weiter, auf dem Land, dann warst du der Größte. Und das war auch richtig toll. Aber das fand ich wirklich so beeindruckend an diesem Fall. Weil man sich dann wirklich von außen betrachtet, stellt sich die Warum-Frage, aber das zeigt ja nur, wie irre manche Dinge im Fußball einfach sind. Und eben auch im Breitensport. Deswegen wollte ich das hier noch mit reinwerfen.
Total interessant, dass du das mit dem Arbeitgeber gesagt hast. Es gibt auch da, das haben wir in die Geschichte nicht mehr reingeschrieben, aber da kann man an der Stelle ja mal sagen, soll das aktuell so sein? Der Verein hat sich weiterentwickelt, da gab es auch eine Fusionierung und so. Und dass es dort in der ländlichen Region einen relativ starken Arbeitgeber gibt, der dort auch Sponsor mit ist und sich jetzt mit den Jahren da wohl eingemischt hat und gesagt hat, wir müssen da mehr darauf achten, dass die Jungs sich hier nicht den Fußball zerstören, sondern auch wieder zur Arbeit gehen können. Und quasi von außen versucht hat, mit einzuwirken, dass es da eine bessere, höhere Sensibilisierung gibt. Noch kurz einen zweiten Gedanken. Ich bin, glaube ich, hier in der Runde derjenige, der am wenigsten aus dem Vereinsfußball leben kommt, auch wenn ich es mal kurz probiert habe in der D&C-Jugend. Aber ich kenne dieses Phänomen tatsächlich auch in dieser Liga, in der ich mit Arne gerade spiele, in der Mediendiga, wo wir gegen andere Medienmannschaften antreten. Und da gibt es dann die heißen Duellen gegen die Z Online, die jetzt vielleicht Kooperationspartner sind, aber auf dem Platz zählt das natürlich nicht mehr. Ich kenne dieses Gefühl, kenne ich glaube ich auch, dass jedes Spiel in dem Moment total wichtig ist und deine Stimmung beeinflusst nach Abpfiff und dass du auch Bock hast, bei solchen Spielen dabei zu sein. Ich habe zwar jetzt noch nicht einmal zu Schmerzbegriffen, aber ich kann total verstehen, wie die Konstruktion zustande kommt und wie das nicht abhängig davon ist, auf was für einer Leistungsebene du kickst.
Also ich will an der Stelle auch nochmal eine Lanze für den Amateurfußball brechen. Natürlich ist es jetzt so, dass ich jetzt hier sitze nach einem Jahr Recherche zum Thema Schmerzmittel mit Bauch und Fußball und jetzt sage, was könnte passieren, damit die Situation sich verbessert und so weiter, aber Full Disclosure an der Stelle, ich habe es natürlich auch selber gemacht, das ist ja keine Frage. Ich habe auch bis letztes Jahr versucht, auf relativ hohem Niveau zu spielen. Das hat auch funktioniert. Ich habe mein Studium damit finanziert und solche Sachen. Ich war da auch finanziell einigermaßen drin. Natürlich war es dann auch so, dass ich, wenn es Freitag im Abschlusstraining mal gezwickt hat, und ich wollte aber Sonntag spielen, weil sonst hätte ich meinen Platz verloren und dann hätte ich wochenlang keine Prämien bekommen, dann habe ich natürlich auch Schmerzmittel genommen. Das ist jetzt dann schon eine Situation, wo ich viele Menschen gut verstehen kann, weil das natürlich auch, wie du schon sagst, Max unheimlich viel zurückgeben kann, wenn man Amateurfußball spielt und mit seinen Freunden spielt in der Mannschaft und dann im besten Fall auch noch erfolgreich ist und so weiter. Das heißt, ich habe diese ganze Geschichte hinter mir. Und trotzdem bin ich eben der Meinung, dass der Fußball auch nicht alles ist, dass man damit nicht unbedingt seine Knochen nachhaltig schädigen muss. Ich habe auch drei Knieoperationen hinter mir. Das heißt, ich glaube, ich weiß, wovon ich spreche. Das ist dann natürlich insofern umso eindrücklicher, wenn ich mich daran erinnere, als ich vor drei Jahren die B-Lizenz gemacht habe beim Hessischen Fußballverband und dann eben auch das Thema Sportmedizin angerissen wurde, um es mal so zu sagen, wie es war. Da kam mal diese klassische Regelung, ja, wenn du eine Verletzung hast, kühl, leg hoch und so weiter. Dann ging es noch um die ideale Sporternährung, das heißt, ist irgendwie eine Banane vom Spiel und so. Und das war es eben. B-Lizenz ist ja dann schon etwas, wo es in den Bereich geht, wo schon einigermaßen versucht wird, dann Fußball zu spielen. Ich habe mir das dann im Nachhinein auch mal gedacht und habe gemerkt, das hat gar keine Rolle gespielt damals. Von daher ist es nicht überraschend, dass die Umfrageergebnisse dann für uns so waren, wie sie waren. Und eben auch dann die Konsequenzen daraus getragen werden müssen für alle Beteiligten. Obwohl, und ich sage es nochmal, der Amateurfußball absolut wichtig ist.
Es ist das gesellschaftliche Ereignis. Und es macht ja auch so unglaublich viel Spaß, Fußball zu spielen. Und deswegen, es wird immer Menschen geben, die bereit sind, viel mehr zu opfern, vielleicht auch ihre Gesundheit für diesen Sport, als wir jetzt vielleicht. Aber wofür man eben sorgen muss, ist, dass alle einen annähernd gleichen Kenntnisstand haben. Dass sie sich bewusst darüber sind, was sie tun. Und dass sie nicht erst mit 35, mit 40 auf einmal Folgeschäden haben, sich vielleicht dann auch gar nicht mehr herleiten können, woher das kommt. Das muss eben verhindert werden. Und da kann man eben nicht einfach nur sagen, das ist jetzt die Verantwortung von einem Einzelnen, sondern das sind die Verbände gefragt, das sind Trainer gefragt. Das sind aber letztlich halt auch wir gefragt. Also ihr natürlich mit eurer Recherche. Ich bin jetzt dann in dem Fall der Multiplikator. Und auch, dass wir auch in unserer sonstigen Berichterstattung... Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt, dass die Leute diese Entscheidung auf diese Thematik hinweisen. Und dann hab ich zumindest ein bisschen ein besseres Gefühl dabei, weil die Leute dann diese Entscheidung bewusst treffen. Aber ich hab eben das Gefühl, dass viele Dinge, also da gibt es einen Gruppenzwang im Fußball sowieso, aber es gibt auch eine hohe Unkenntnis. Und ich weiß auch noch aus meiner Fußballerfahrung, da gab es diesen einen Trainer im Nachbarort, der mit Mitte 30, Anfang 30 nicht mehr Fußball spielen konnte, der bis heute hinkt und der war der Held, der war der Größte. Weil der mal ein ganz guter Kicker war, weil er viele Tore geschossen hat. Und weil er jetzt auch noch Jugendtrainer ist im Fußball. Und der war quasi der, wo alle gesagt haben, geiler Typ. Der hinkt jetzt, schauen die an, wie geil. Und das ist ja so völlig irre. Und das habe ich aber natürlich auch nicht geschneit. Aber auch sowas muss man halt hinterfragen, finde ich.
Und bei solchen Biografien finde ich es wichtig zu verstehen, wie es den Leuten eigentlich wirklich geht damit. Ob, also, neben der öffentlichen Chlorifizierung und den Sprüchen, die sie bekommen, die vielleicht sich auch gut anfühlen in dem Moment, selbst wenn man irgendwie so ein schweres körperliches Leiden später hat, stehen wir aber schon bei vielen die Frage, wie es denen wirklich geht. Ja, also ob es, es gibt ja, da können wir ja zig Beispiele suchen. Also Otto Ado war doch damals auch was, Uefa Cup oder Uefa Cup.
Ja, mit gerissenem Kreuzband hat er noch im Sitzen ein Tor erzielt für Borussia Dortmund.
Ja, genau, solche Sachen hat man noch in Erinnerung heute, obwohl das irgendein Spiel war. Vielleicht den Gegner weiß man wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, aber du vielleicht schon. Aber irgendwie hat man sich deswegen an diese besondere Situation erinnert und dafür wird dann sicherlich auch noch gefeiert werden. Oder der Stadionsprecher von Borussia Dortmund hat auch so einiges durchgemacht und musste nach dem Pokalfinale damals, glaube ich, dann seine Karriere beenden und wird dafür auch noch gefeiert. Und bei den Leuten finde ich es wirklich interessant, sich die Zeit zu nehmen, mit denen abseits der Öffentlichkeit zu sprechen und zu verstehen, wie es ihnen eigentlich damit geht. Ja, dann sagen sie vielleicht immer noch, sie hätten es genauso gemacht, aber wie sieht der Alltag wirklich aus? Und das ist das, was man sonst nicht sieht. Wenn da ein paar Leute mehr öffentlich darüber reden und sich auch mal trauen, das öffentlich zu nennen. Eine Idee von uns ist ja auch, wir wissen nicht, ob das eine Dynamik erreicht, vielleicht auch über den Rasenfunk wieder. Wir haben ja dieses Hashtag Pillenkick, das erwähne ich natürlich jetzt sehr spät. Sowas muss man früher unterbringen.
Die Rasenfunkerinnen und Funker hören schon durch, keine Angst.
Das ist stark, okay. Also Hashtag Pillenkick. Eine Idee ist, dass wir darunter auch gerne weitere Geschichten hören wollen. Also wir und auch dadurch Leute ermutigen wollen, dass sie auch ihre Erlebnisse, die sie selber erlebt haben, oder weil sie es selber oder bei anderen Personen einfach mal erzählen. Auf welcher Plattform auch immer. Ich denke jetzt natürlich in erster Linie an Twitter, aber sowas funktioniert auch auf Instagram und auf anderen Plattformen. Und dass man dadurch auch ein bisschen Sensibilisierung schafft, gerade was den Amateurbereich betrifft. Eine andere Sache, die wir auch machen wollen, wenn ich kurz noch diesen kleinen Werbeblock anschieben kann. Also für alle, die jetzt früh den Rasenfunk hören, wäre natürlich belohnt, weil am Donnerstagabend wir einen Livestream machen werden, wo Jonas Hummels dabei ist. Hoffentlich auch ein Amateurfußballer. Und vielleicht ja noch ein weiterer Sportler. Das müssen wir jetzt alles noch sehen, wie sich das die Tage entwickelt. Aber Jonas Hummels ist schon mal sicher dabei, bevor er abends als Kommentator noch tätig ist. Und wir wollen über die ganzen Sachen reden. Und auch gerne möglichst mit Leuten, die sich von außen Fragen stellen, Tag über oder auch während des Livestreams. Also da freuen wir uns auch, wenn sich mehrere Leute dazuschalten. Das wird sich dann auf der YouTube-Plattform von Correctiv abspielen.
Genau, am 11. Juni ist das. Also wir nehmen jetzt am 8. Juni gerade auf. Und für die ganz schnellen gibt es ja schon am Dienstag, am Erscheinungstag dieses Tribünengesprächs, abends die Doku, aus der wir jetzt ja auch schon Teilzitate gehört haben, direkt im Anschluss an ein Spiel von, jetzt sage ich auch den Namen, Bayer Leverkusen, weil ihr Freunde auch schon auf die Ironie hingewiesen hattet. Jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, die wichtigsten Sachen, die man noch weitergehend sich damit befassen kann, angesprochen. Ich würde aber gerne zwei...
Du war dazu noch ein kleines Ritze, ja? Sowas macht mir ein bisschen Spaß. Also einer der Akteure, die dort in dem Kader stehen, mit denen haben wir auch sehr ausführlich gesprochen. Wollte sich nicht öffentlich äußern, aber es war ein super Gespräch. Jetzt könnt ihr das Spiel nochmal aus einer ganz anderen Perspektive betrachten.
Und aus dem Kader von Leverkusen oder von Saarbrücken? Oder magst du das nicht sagen?
Soweit kann ich jetzt noch nicht sagen. Vielleicht sind es sogar zwei. Da müsst ihr jetzt nochmal alle Namen checken.
Guck an, guck an, guck an. Ich würde gerne noch auf zwei Aspekte eingehen und dann entlasse ich euch in euer Post-Pre-Lounge-Wahnsinn. Und zwar zum einen den Bereich der Jugendlichen und vielleicht auch der Jugendlichen, die jetzt zwar vielleicht noch im Freizeit- oder im Amateursport unterwegs sind, aber die Möglichkeit haben, in den Leistungssport zu kommen. Also die eben über DFB-Stützpunkte oder über Nachwuchsleistungszentren dann an den Profifußball herangeführt werden könnten. Ist das Problem eurer Rechercheerfahrung nach da größer? Es erschien ja logisch, weil der Druck ja auch größer ist und der Wunsch auch größer ist, es zu schaffen.
Ob das Problem jetzt größer ist, wage ich jetzt nicht zu beurteilen, aber zumindest haben wir festgestellt, dass es zumindest ein Thema ist. Also dass Schmerzmittel dort auch ein wesentlicher Bestandteil sind, also gerade in Nachwuchsleistungszentren, bei denen dann die U19-Mannschaften beispielsweise auch in der Youth League spielen. Also da haben wir auch einen Text zugemacht, wo wir das thematisieren, sodass eben dort die Spieler auch eine hohe Belastung haben. Alle zwei, drei Tage spielen und dann eben auch entsprechend regenerieren müssen. Und da haben wir eben erfahren, dass da eben auch Schmerzmittel ein Teil davon sind. Und wir reden hier von 16-, 17-, 18-Jährigen. Und die FIFA-Studien haben eben auch aufgezeigt, dass bei den U17-Turnieren Schmerzmittel genommen wurden. Und das ist dann natürlich insofern beunruhigend, dass eben Jugendliche, bzw. auch Kinder dann zum Teil, in eine Situation kommen, wo sie mit Medikamenten einen Zustand erreichen sollen, damit sie einen Sport betreiben können. Und das finde ich problematisch, weil natürlich ein jugendlicher Körper nochmal ganz andere Herausforderungen zu bewältigen hat als jetzt ein Erwachsenerprofi. Also da ist ja das Thema Wachstum und Knie-Schmerzen durch schnelles Wachstum usw. Das haben vielleicht alle hinter uns und so. Und dann dagegen anzukämpfen mit Schmerzmitteln ist natürlich problematisch. Und natürlich ist auch so, dass dann ab der U19, wenn wir über den Bereich reden, die Spieler in den Nachwuchsleistungszentren unter einem großen Druck stehen, dass sie auch dann eben die Möglichkeit kriegen, eventuell einen Anschlussvertrag als Profi zu bekommen. Und da haben wir natürlich auch dann Aussagen bekommen, von wegen, ja, natürlich habe ich da ein Schmerzmittel genommen, ich will ja mal einen Profi-Vertrag bekommen. Und da reden wir dann eben über eine Situation, wo jemand versucht, sein Abitur eventuell zu machen oder seinen Schulabschluss zu machen, im Alter von 18 bis 19, regelmäßig dann vielleicht mit den Profis schon mal trainiert oder so und dann auch noch in der U19 spielt. Das ist natürlich eine wahnsinnige Belastung für einen jungen Menschen. Und wenn man dann schon anfängt, quasi diese Spirale reinzuberaten, dass Schmerzmittel als Regeneration oder als Prävention oder was auch immer dann eben genommen werden, dann kommt es ja nicht von ungefähr, dass dann eben die Situation ein paar Jahre später im Profibereich so ist, wie sie ist.
Und ihr habt es vorhin schon mal ganz kurz angesprochen, dass ihr auch die Nachwuchsleistungszentren angeschrieben hattet, an einem recht frühen Punkt eurer Recherche. Habt ihr das Gefühl, dass da vielleicht sich jetzt auch innerhalb dieses Jahres, seit Beginn der Recherche und jetzt endlich die Veröffentlichung, da schon etwas getan hat? Oder die Hoffnung, dass sich da jetzt etwas tun wird hinsichtlich Bewusstsein auch in den Strukturen dort? Die sind ja eigentlich auch dafür da, die Spieler vielleicht auch mal vor dem eigenen Ehrgeiz zu schützen.
Da fehlt mir komplett das Gefühl, muss ich sagen. Da haben wir auch keine Indizien, dass irgendeine Debatte dort im Gang ist. Also ich weiß nicht, ob du das anders siehst, aber das ist für mich ein ganz dünner Fleck. Ich glaube, die sind auch sehr unterschiedlich. Dann ist ja die Frage, reden wir nur von den Profileistungszentren oder denen auch darunter. Ich weiß nicht, Anna, hast du dazu nur eine andere Position?
Ja, natürlich hoffe ich schon, dass da was passiert. Und natürlich auch auf Ebene der Eltern auch. Das ist ja auch ein ganz wichtiger Faktor in dem Zusammenhang, dass man als Elternteil realisiert, okay, was macht mein Sohn jetzt so? Was ist so sein Tagesablauf? Wie sieht es aus mit seiner Belastung? Ist er genug geschützt, ist er genug aufgeklärt in Bezug auf dieses Thema? Und nochmal, es spricht ja nichts dagegen, wenn jemand eine strukturelle Verletzung vermeiden kann und eben ein Schmerzmittel nimmt, einmal im Monat, alles cool. Das ist ja wirklich nicht das Problem. Aber das Problem beginnt dann eben, und da möchte ich noch mal darauf hinweisen, wenn das missbräuchlich passiert, das heißt, wenn das regelmäßig passiert, wenn das ohne medizinische Indikationen passiert. Und ja, vielleicht ist es dann so, dass eine TV-Doku zu dem Thema bei Leuten, die da drin oder die damit zu tun haben, mal dann so den Reflexionsprozess auslöst, wo man dann sich mal hinterfragt und guckt, okay, wie ist das jetzt in meinem Arbeitsalltag eigentlich? Wie ist das in meinem Trainingsalltag? Und das ist natürlich auch ein Thema für die NSZ dann, klar.
Und jetzt haben wir quasi, wir haben begonnen beim Profifußball, wir haben weitergemacht beim Freizeitfußball oder dem Freizeitsport. Lass noch kurz, aber wir müssen jetzt nicht in die Tiefe gehen. Wie groß ist denn das Thema Schmerzmittelmissbrauch, Medikamentenmissbrauch in der Gesellschaft? Ist das vielleicht auch noch ein blinder Fleck, den man vielleicht haben kann?
Ich denke schon, dass man sich damit auch auseinandersetzen sollte. Also Correctiv, jetzt um den Claim auch nochmal zu bringen, macht ja die Fährschung für die Gesellschaft und mit der Gesellschaft. Von daher war diese Frage für uns eigentlich auch immer so ein bisschen leitend, dass wir eben schauen, wie sieht das jetzt in anderen Situationen aus. Und wenn man heute Abend Tagesschau guckt und dann die Werbeslots davor, was kommt da eigentlich in 90% der Fällen? Das ist Werbung für Schmerzmittel. Das heißt, wir haben da schon eine sehr exponierte Position für Schmerzmittel, die offensiv beworben werden auf verschiedenen Plattformen. Und natürlich ist es so, wenn wir die Gesamtgesellschaft uns anschauen, dass wir dann auch gucken müssen, wie sind die Zahlen bei älteren Menschen, was passiert durch Verschreibungen, was passiert in der Selbstmedikation. Und es ist natürlich schon auch so, dass man überlegen muss, welche systemische Rolle spielen da Ärzte und Apotheken? Haben Ärzte immer die Zeit, einen Schmerz von einem Patienten oder einer Patientin so zu ergründen, dass auch wirklich die Ursache bekämpft werden kann und nicht das Symptom? Das heißt, Symptombekämpfung wäre quasi zu sagen, hier hast du eine Verschreibung für ein Schmerzmittel, geh in die Apotheke, hol dir das. Wenn die Ursache bekämpft werden soll, brauche ich erstmal Zeit, dann muss ich ein Gespräch führen, dann muss ich gucken, wie geht es meinem Patienten, meiner Patientin. Und ich habe den Eindruck aus den Gesprächen, die ich geführt habe, dass das nicht immer der Fall ist. Dass durch die Kommerzialisierung des Gesundheitswesens da auch Zeit und Geld natürlich eine Rolle spielen. Und nicht jede Apothekerin und nicht jeder Apothekerin das sicherstellen, dass auch immer, wenn eine Person kommt und eben sagt, ich brauche Ibuprofen 400, dass dann im Dialog geklärt wird, ob Ibuprofen 400 in dem Fall tatsächlich das Richtige ist. Oder ob es das nicht sogar noch schlimmer macht. Und wir haben uns eben auch mit den Datenlagen beschäftigt zu diesem Thema. Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass in Deutschland mehr Menschen von Medikamenten abhängig sind als von Alkohol tatsächlich. Und das ist mir auch nicht so bewusst gewesen.
Ja, das hat mich auch überrascht.
Und natürlich ist es dann auch so, dass das für den Alltag eine Rolle spielt. Ich meine, wie oft ist es so, dass man mit einer Schmerztablette morgens versucht, eine Krankheit zu unterdrücken und trotzdem an die Arbeit geht und dann im Endeffekt alles nur noch schlimmer wird und man eine Woche zu Hause bleiben muss. Diese Fälle gibt es ja auch. Und da können wir nur jetzt unter Berücksichtigung von dem, was wir als Ergebnisse haben, wirklich dazu oder da appellieren, dass man da gut überlegt, in welchem Fall man Schmerz mitnimmt und in welchem Fall nicht, in dem Text, den wir dazu gemacht haben, bringen wir dann auch noch die Beispiele aus anderen Sportarten. Das hatten wir eben auch schon angesprochen. Und da ist es natürlich auch so, dass mir im Gedächtnis geblieben ist, dass vor Marathonläufen, wie zum Beispiel dem New York Marathon, da gab es so einen Starterbeutel für alle Leute, die daran teilgenommen haben. Und da waren schon prophylaktisch die Schmerzmittel drin.
Es ist eigentlich so irre, wenn man da drüber nachdenkt.
Und ich konnte das nicht glauben. Ich habe dann versucht, das zu verifizieren, habe das dann auch hinbekommen. Und es ist natürlich absurd. Ich meine, wir machen Sport aus gewissen Gründen. Und natürlich gehört beim Marathon auch die Überwindung dazu. Aber das Starterbeutel schon prophylaktisch, die Schmerzmittel, das ist natürlich Wahnsinn. Und da müssen wir auf jeden Fall alle ein bisschen behutsamer, ein bisschen achtsamer vielleicht sein. Und das mal hinterfragen, zu welchen Zeitpunkten Schmerzmittel dann eben genommen werden.
Und auch da noch mal das Thema Opioide. Das ist zumindest etwas, was man, glaube ich, genau beobachten muss in Zukunft, weil hier die Zahlen steigen, der Opioide. Man darf das nicht vergleichen mit den USA. Da spielen die Apotheker eine ganz entscheidende Rolle, dass sie es zufällig ausgeben, dass auch ein Geschäftsmodell ist, quasi Apotheker als Dealer, so in die Richtung. Und an der Stelle gibt es eine tolle Netflix-Dokumentation zu dem ganzen Thema, die die Opioid-Krise sehr gut aufgearbeitet hat. Und den Namen weiß ich natürlich jetzt nicht, aber ich glaube, das kriegt man schnell heraus. Vier Teile sind es. Und in Deutschland ist die Struktur insofern ein bisschen anders, dass wir hier eine stärkere Regulierung haben. Du hattest gefragt, Opioide und Betäubungsmittel. Ich habe jetzt gerade parallel nochmal geschaut. Genau, es gibt das Betäubungsmittelgesetz. Darüber wird definiert, dass Opioide auch nochmal gesondert dokumentiert werden müssen. Also das, was in den USA ist, dass die Apotheker an ganz viele Opioide rankommt und die dann weiter frei rausgibt und das sonst nicht so richtig erfasst wird, das ist hier nicht so möglich. Da müsste man schon über andere illegale Wege gehen. Aber trotzdem gibt es diesen Anstieg. Und den muss man glaube ich genau beobachten, was das genau bedeutet. Also ob vielleicht trotzdem zu leichtfertig Opioide verschrieben werden oder zu langfristig. Oder es keine Nachbegleitung gibt, wenn man jemand angefangen hat damit und vielleicht süchtig geworden ist und der dann nicht genug aufgefangen wird und sich über andere Wege das besorgt oder so.
Die Netflix-Doku ist glaube ich The Pharmacist. Dieser vier Teile, haben wir das auch noch geklärt. Ja und ich finde einen interessanten Nebenaspekt einfach nur für den Hinterkopf, finde ich, ist wichtig zu wissen, dass eben Schmerzmittel auch ein wesentlicher Umsatztreiber für Apotheken sind. Also von einem Gesamtumsatz von 7,1 Milliarden Euro. Laut Bundesverband der Arzneimittelhersteller im Jahr 2018 entfällt etwas mehr als eine Milliarde auf Schmerzmittel. Da sieht man die Dimensionen, die das hat. Und das erklärt vielleicht dann auch sowohl die offensive Werbeplatzierung als auch vielleicht, ohne etwas unterstellen zu wollen. Aber dann kann man auch sagen, wenn Neven Zubotic ganz am Anfang unseres Gesprächs im O-Ton gesagt hat, Schmerzmittel werden im Profifußball genommen wie Smarties, so ganz weit weg scheinen wir dann in der Gesellschaft auch nicht davon zu sein, wenn eine Milliarde von 7 Milliarden Umsatz über Schmerzmittel erzielt werden in den Apotheken. Absolut. Jetzt habe ich nur noch zwei Fragen an euch. Was heißt nur noch? Ihr habt euch sehr viel Zeit genommen. Einmal kann vielleicht Arne zuerst beantworten und Jonathan hat dann noch den Luxus, sich länger Gedanken zu machen über seine Antwort. Wenn ihr euch jetzt etwas wünschen könntet, was jetzt nach dieser Recherche passiert, jenseits von Pulitzer-Preisen und ARD-Thementagen wegen eurer Recherche, was wäre denn das, Arne?
Definitiv, dass das Thema Schmerzmittel übernommen wird in die Trainerausbildung und Trainerinnenausbildung im DFB, egal ob das jetzt dezentral stattfindet oder zentral, aber das muss irgendwie an die Menschen kommen, das muss an die Menschen kommen, die im Amateurfußball-Fußball spielen. Und das ist ganz, ganz entscheidend, dass die Leute, die dort in der Verantwortung stehen, dafür sensibilisiert sind und dafür ein Auge haben. Und eben grundsätzlich ein bisschen mehr auf Gesundheit geachtet wird. Das ist erstmal eine Ebene Amateurfußball, eine Ebene Profi-Fußball. Bin ich natürlich ein bisschen skeptischer, dass sich da was verändert. Aber das ist ja auch eine Debatte, die wir schon seit längerer Zeit führen. Wie viel Fußball braucht es überhaupt? Und wie viel Fußball ist nötig? Wie viel Fußball ist gesund? Und ich glaube, was ich eben auch schon mal sagte, dass dort auch die Bewusstseinsschärfung quasi helfen würde, Geld zu sparen. Denn in diesem kommerzialisierten Business ist natürlich einer der wesentlichen Punkte oder eines der Interessen, Geld zu sparen oder eben Geld zu generieren, was auch immer. Und da kann man auch an Hebelschmerzmittel einsetzen, keine Frage. Und ja, das sind eben eine Amateurfußball, eine Profi-Fußball. Gesamtgesellschaftlich habe ich eben auch schon mal kurz erwähnt, dass man mal hinterfragt, wenn man vor dem Gang in die Apotheke überlegt, brauche ich das jetzt oder brauche ich das nicht. Aber ich bin mir sicher, Jonathan hat auch noch sehr, sehr gute Ideen.
Er hat ja auch mehr Zeit.
Ja, ich habe nicht so konkret. Du hattest sogar die konkreteren Ideen jetzt. Bei mir ist mehr was Generelles. Ich würde es total gut finden, wenn darüber einfach viel offener gesprochen wird. Also was wir alles so thematisiert haben, harte Jungsmentalität, immer weitermachen, was sozusagen auf allen Ebenen eine Rolle spielt und dass man viel mehr öffentlich hinterfragt und auch in Diskussionen tritt. Das muss, glaube ich, auf der untersten Ebene passieren, innerhalb eines Vereins mit einem Mitspieler, deren vielleicht die Sachen gibt, auch mal kritisch was anmerkt, wenn jemand sich das einwirft und sich traut zu sagen, ich glaube, das ist nicht so klug, dass du es jetzt so ein Spiel machst. Und irgendwie die Evo 800 oder irgendeine andere Dosierung oder was anderes nimmst, dass man einfach zu dem Thema mehrere Menschen auch eine kritische Grundhaltung einnimmt, was den Missbrauch betrifft, nicht generell jetzt Schmerzmittel, aber dadurch so ein Fenster geöffnet wird. Und das beginnt ja nur, wenn Leute anfangen, da sich selber vielleicht was einzugestehen und sich das Kritische anschauen und dann gibt es vielleicht ein paar mehr kritische Töne auf der ganz lokalen Ebene, Vereinsebene. Und dann kann die Debatte zustande kommen. Und ob das dann auch noch quasi in eine Online-Debatte überschlägt, das würde ich auch sehr spannend finden. Aber ich glaube, erst mal ist es sogar was sehr Persönliches, was im Zweier- und Dreiergespräch, im Vierer-Gespräch eher angestoßen werden muss. Und da kommen genau solche Sachen rein, die Arne jetzt schon mal als konkrete Vorstellung gemacht hat, dass es erst mal in so Tagungen und so reinkommt, damit überhaupt eine Debatte möglich ist. Aber vielleicht lesen die auch ganz viele Menschen und schauen die Doku und die Recherche und danach diskutieren sie mal am nächsten Tag. Und nicht nur einen Tag, sondern eine Woche später auch noch. Schade, dass sie sich gerade nicht so treffen, außer ab und zu beim Training in kleinen Gruppen auf Amateur-Ebene. Das ist jetzt nicht das perfekte Timing, aber der Austausch ist ja trotzdem da.
Gut, dann habe ich abschließend nur noch eine Frage. Wer von euch beiden war derjenige, der auf die Fußballspieler von Rasenball Sport Leipzig gewartet hat, um sie abzufangen und dann auf seinem Fahrrad nicht hinter ihren E-Bikes hinterhergekommen ist?
Ich glaube, du folgst mich so richtig auf Instagram und meinen Stories. Da war doch vor einem Jahr eine Story.
Also, wie konnte ich das übersehen?
Aber man muss dazu mal kurz auflösen. Wir haben das damals so gemacht, dass Arne in den Alpen wesentlich mehr Trainingslagern war. Und ich aus privaten Gründen nur einen Trainingslager mitnehmen konnte. Das war dann bei RB Leipzig. Max, hilf mir auf die Sprünge, ich bin Rasenfunkanfänger. Nicht RB Leipzig.
Raber Leipzig, natürlich. Wir sind der Rabe.
Ich hatte den Luxus, dass ich da dann zwei Tage am Stück mehr angucken konnte, wie man es am besten machen konnte. Nur mal für den Hintergrund, den wir gerade nicht verstehen. Wir haben uns damals eine Strategie gemacht, dass wir in den Trainingslagern schauen, was da eigentlich alles so los ist. Da hatten wir verschiedene Fragestellungen. Werden die von irgendwelchen externen dubiosen Ärzten besucht, die man sonst nicht so kennt, so ein bisschen außerhalb der Öffentlichkeit in den Alpen versteckt. Was liegt eigentlich so im Müll der Vereine rum? Also wer unsere Recherche aus der Vergangenheit kennt, weiß, dass wir in der Vergangenheit auch schon mal in den Müll von Nationalmannschaften damals geschaut haben und bei der ukrainischen Nationalmannschaft Infusionsbesteck und sowas gefunden haben. Und wir dachten, das wäre was, das kann man vielleicht auch in den Bundesligisten machen, was da so in den Müllcontainern verschwindet. Aber ein ganz wichtiger Punkt war, das war eigentlich der Zentrale. Wir wollten mit mehreren Akteuren aus dem Profisport einfach dort in Gespräche kommen. Weil im Trainingslager generell die Leute eher mehr Zeit haben als in der normalen Saison. Und da gab es die Situation, wo ich versucht habe, auf Mountainbikes mit den Spielern Kontakt zu treten. Aber das lösen wir jetzt nicht auf, oder? Mal so eine Sache, so ein ganz bisschen Teaser.
Ich fürchte, mit meiner Frage habe ich schon so leicht angedeutet.
Aber wir erzählen jetzt... Da zeigt sich dann eben auch der Unterschied zwischen einem fitten Journalisten und...
Ja, aber das Interessante war ja, ich habe damals in dem Radladen nachgefragt, wo sich die Leipziger ihre Räder ausgeliehen haben, wie das genau ablief. Die Jugendspieler von Leipzig, die haben keine E-Bikes bekommen. Das sind nur die Profis, die mussten das ganze Ding, so wie ich, den Anstieg so bewältigen.
Ja, und das ist auch klar, dass Arne da natürlich einen spöttischen Kommentar macht. Dabei wissen wir jetzt inzwischen alle, dass Arne nur deshalb beim Correctiv ist, damit man Zeit online auf dem Platz so richtig lang machen kann, weil Arne ja mal für Prämien höherklassigen Fußball gespielt hat. Das ist alles genau abgespeichert, Arne. Also, ich danke euch sehr herzlich für eure Zeit. Das ist auch nicht leichter hingesagt. Noch mal zur Erinnerung. Wir sind hier am Abend vor dem Launch eurer Seite pillenkick.de. Das Hashtag dazu ist ebenfalls Pillenkick. Ihr findet alle Links in den Shownotes. Und das möchte ich auch noch mal herausstreichen. Ihr findet auch dort, wie man das Correctiv unterstützen kann. Das Correctiv ist Deutschlands erstes gemeinnütziges, finanziertes Recherche-Forum und lebt eben...
Recherche-Zentrum.
Zentrum, wie konnte ich das sagen? Der Unterschied ist ja auch riesig. Aber ist eben auch von der ganzen ideellen Grundstruktur her sehr nah am Rasenfunk. Und wer eben etwas wie den Rasenfunk unterstützt, wofür ich ja unglaublich dankbar bin, dem liegt es vielleicht auch nahe, so etwas wie das Correctiv zu unterstützen. Und ihr habt jetzt in den letzten zwei Stunden nicht nur viel über Schmerzmittel-Bissbruch erfahren, sondern auch über die Arbeitsweise des Correctivs und der ARD-Dopingredaktion. Und da dürfte relativ klar geworden sein, hoffe ich zumindest, dass das eine langfristige, eine nachhaltige Recherchearbeit ist. Und es gibt ganz sicher auch Recherchen, die auch nach einem Jahr dann vielleicht zu keinem Ergebnis führen, wo es dann eben auch kein tolles Tribüngespräch zu gibt, die aber auch geführt werden müssen. Und da muss man eben den Journalismus auch ein bisschen unter die Arme greifen. Auch gerade jetzt, wo sich manche Dinge im Journalismus ein bisschen beschleunigen, die schon vorher in Schieflage waren, was eben die Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten angeht. Deshalb guckt euch auch mal die Seite des Correctivs an. Das wollte ich an dieser Stelle noch loswerden. Und dann danke ich euch beiden sehr herzlich. Zum einen Jonathan Sachse, man kann ihm folgen auf Instagram. Das machen ja sowieso alle. Und aber auch auf Twitter, da ist er, jjsachsejonathan, danke dir, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Vielen Dank. Folgt mir lieber auf Instagram, da macht es mir gerade mehr Spaß.
Okay, okay, ja, und man bekommt halt schon auch so Sneak-Previews in die nächste Recherche rein. Da wissen wir jetzt natürlich dann, was los ist, wenn du wieder in den Alpen unterwegs bist. Und herzlichen Dank auch an Arne Steinberg. Auch gerade nochmal, Arne, dass du auch aus deinem persönlichen Erfahrungsbereich erzählt hast, das fand ich sehr spannend. Et arne unterstrich steinberg bei Twitter, danke dir Arne für deine Zeit. Das ist doch völlig logisch. Dieses Thema passt ja wie die Faust aus Auge zum Rasenfunk. Wobei ich nicht weiß, ob diese Analogie beim Thema Schmerzmittel dann wirklich die glücklichste war. Es ist vielleicht dann Zeit, diese Sendung zu beenden. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Danke für all euren Support. Ihr könnt auch gerne in die weiteren Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräche hören. Da gibt es auch einige noch, unter anderem mit Jonathan. Wir haben natürlich auch über Doping im Fußball schon ganz, ganz früh gesprochen. Das ist schon sehr lange her. Habt eine gute Zeit, liebe Hörerinnen. Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Ganz souverän, nur die Frauen verabschiedet, naja.